vous allez levez la main moi là là là
bravo
ouais je l'aimé aussi
[Musique]
oui
on est aujourd'hui chez wam poule pour
parler cuisine connecter pour parler
faut connecter pour parler micro-ondes
connecter pour parler mode connecté et
on a même un chef connecter avec nos
voilà comme ça on n'est pas tout seul
bien notre chèque ne regarde pas ce truc
là revoilà
mais non mais là je la prends comme ça
est en train de manger voilà c'est la
surprise
il faut bien manger un petit peu super
serait qu est-ce que tout à fait beau il
fait les projets liés qu'ils trient avec
un rodrigue
c'était juste magnifique tout ça sur les
appareils d'une poule de la nouvelle
gamme qui s'appelle du pv 11w 11 ça
c'est magnifique ce qui fait que on a
une tablette jeu tout vous expliquer en
détail on a une tablette et on peut tous
connectés ensemble
en gros si vous voulez l'idée c'est que
j'ai eu entre elles ce fax elle ce fac
d'arts l'extérieur l'idée c'est qu'on
sent vite plus on a envie de cuisiner
mais on n'a pas envie de s'endetter vous
prenez une recette vous la faites
rapidement vous envoyer tout ça presov
sa shot donne les bonnes températures
c'est magnifique c'est beau c'est
pratique c'est limpide et on va regarder
ça petit canon et sac mais ce coût est
énorme
hamon
kendall commencé mardi soir
awano
[Musique]
accueil
fac mais khelifa chat audio à deux
guaino
hamada
que nenni
l envie de ça non
[Musique]
quand du maillage seule salle ça dérange
pas de cet ennemi par les ailes comme ça
dans la rue les gens me prennent pour un
fou
aux etats unis ce doit être le courant
aux états unis c'est plus c'est plus
facile mais ça dépend en fait voilà
c'était très bon iv lever la main moi là
là là à
bravo ouais tu es mais aussi la mare aux
normes et de me voir la chine a félicité
on est tous d'accord c'était très bon
[Applaudissements]
non mais sans témoin aux jeux super vrai
voilà la maîtrise de notre mission
c'était vraiment très bien merci
beaucoup c'est grâce au doublé 11e
tournoi
alors comment ça marche donc l'achat
d'applications avec mes différents
appareils haute four micro-ondes livre
de recettes parce qu'il faut savoir que
j'ai des recettes qui sont inclus dans
la tablette mais également dans le four
ou d'un micron ça c'est intéressant et
puis l'hérault c'est surtout son sont
mises à jours il ya de nouvelles
recettes qui sont complètement
compatible vraiment optimisé rajouter
tous les mois donc ça c'est intéressant
donc là on va râler par exemple tient le
foie alors le four qu'est-ce que je peux
faire nouveau type de cuisson
je vais allumer les fours en même temps
à distance un voyage entre vraiment tous
les réglages de mon faux mois la maison
j'en ai un comme ça donc ce sixième sens
on va se faire coindre tira goût des
lasagnes congelé à les formidables le
plat familial
ça ne donne le temps j'ai la fonction
j'ai le poids que de pouvoir venir
paramétrer ici en fonction du haut de
mon plat pas mal ça c'est vraiment très
intuitif donc là j'ai des détails sur
différents plats poulet tandoori des
recettes par exemple
donc là typiquement je vais voir la
recette du poulet tandoori plat
principal
youri j'ai des notes parce que même en
estimant mes propres notes ça c'est
intéressant et j'ai les ingrédients que
je peux ajouter après à ma liste de
courses
donc ça c'est aussi hyper cool et après
ça va me guider pas à pas pour faire ma
recette je clique sur des bus et là j'ai
plusieurs étapes donc la résume gagne à
la gnagna je vais étape suivante est à 2
et là ça me dit comment le préparer
enlevez la peau des cuisses de poulets
bon je vous passe un peu le truc un peu
technique donc là ça donne mais étape
mettre la sauce son cas c'est vraiment
une recette qui guidé pas à pas c'est
franchement franchement intéressant
pourquoi j'envoie le tout au four et hop
le four soft c'est parti on n'en parle
plus et là je le montre avec le four est
ce que faire de la même manière avec la
micro ondes pour mes quiche aux asperges
et au safran par exemple je peux le
faire également de la même manière
qu'avec la haute
donc je peux modifier l'éclairage de ma
haute je peux régler mon aspiration voir
le niveau de mon filtre à charbon s'il
faut changer les filtres à gré sans fin
c'est vraiment intéressant
on va y avoir un peu la navigation du
côté du four fonctions manuelles fonds
sixième sens on va le faire dans sixième
sens liste d'aliments sans ce style de
vie style fait facile rapide plats du
monde gt1 c'est la fête
laza à la zaïne lasagnes cannellonis
canet l'audience est assez c'est
vraiment la fête
là c'est plus avec une sonde la cdu
surgelés bon personnellement ça fait un
peu mode cinéaste je balance 500 grammes
j'envoie temps de cuisson estimé sylvain
petit ordinateur
c'est assez oufa instructions qui sont
pour le tactile et à séoul
là je me dis qu'en fait j'ai pas sur une
tablette jeu sur l'écran monfort le
tactile est franchement hyper cool mais
ce qui est vraiment intéressant avec ce
ses solutions au niveau de la maison
connectée et la de la cuisine connectés
c'est vraiment deux rangs plus facile en
fait la proche de la cuisine pour rendre
plus facile le côté justement cuisine
auckland a les infos sur les
instructions préparation tous en
retrouve sur les tablettes
comment le préparer qu'est-ce qu'il faut
mettre dedans mais ça c'est vachement
cool la jemaye début là j'ai mon four
qui s'allume alors là monfort a été
utilisé donc il est encore été nettoyée
en plus ce qui est cool c'est que je
peux complètement m
différents plats sur quatre niveaux
parce que j'ai une ventilation qui est
assez ouf
et du coup je n'ai pas avoir de
problèmes d'odeurs et les plats vont pas
venir polluer les uns les autres et là
j'ai un écran couleur avec ce à quoi
devrait ressembler mon plat à quelque
chose près je suis pas sûre de mettre la
petite feuille sur le dessus mais en
tout cas c'est vrai que c'est très
intuitif
très pratique et là j'ai différents
outils alors c'est quoi ça activation à
distance les mini tri l'éclairage alors
il serait une sonde à ça c'est super
cool mais je peux utiliser le son pour
vraiment me donner avec quatre points
différents savoir exactement la
température de cuisson température à
coeur donc c'est pareil sa boutique est
super cool
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors verdict éclairage doux dessus
comme ça verdict enfin que des solutions
comme celles qu'on a la même poule que
ce soit pour le réfrigérateur qui est un
peu moins connectés qu'une race mais le
réfrigérateur
je pense au micro ondes je pense
vraiment fou à la haute
ça vous permet en fait d'avoir un
écosystème complet qui est intéressante
pour les personnes qui aiment bien
manger mais qui veulent absolument pas
s'embêter à cuisiner c'est une façon
simple intuitive et efficace de ce qu'a
compris des complètement sa cuisine on a
une liste de courses on achète au su des
étapes pas par pas le fourre-tout se
préchauffe tout pas en temps et en heure
est vraiment s'embête pas alors vous me
direz on peut très bien réglé son four
directement c'est une certitude
il existe déjà des applications prendra
des recettes de cuisine c'est une
certitude mais l'intérêt est la vraie
force de rennes coup là dessus c'est
vraiment d'avoir un écosystème simple
vous vous endettez pas vous avez votre
application vous avez votre tablette
vous avez tous c'est direct sa part
c'est franchement cool ça c'est vraiment
intéressant alors chez moi je t'ai qui
parviennent poule dans la cuisine depuis
deux trois ans j'ai pas à les produits
qu'on a là mais c'est vrai que dans une
super envie à la maison c'est moi qui
cuisine c'est moi le chef est vrai j j
paradoxe mais c'est moi le chef pas du
tout ma compagne qu'elle s'y met quand
même pas dire le contraire c'est le
regardera j'aime faire engueuler je fais
ma cuisine et je trouve que ce système
là est vraiment bien parce que des fois
je sais j'ai alors qu'est ce que je peux
aujourd'hui des pages du riz du soja je
fais des endives jeter délais
comme toujours eu comme plat et là pour
le coup avec ça je sais au moins que
j'ai acheté les ingrédients dont j'ai
vraiment besoin de gentils citer les
besoins de leurs amis qu anticipé ma
liste de courses de la semaine
ensuite il qu'à suivre papa et lorsqu'on
rentre du boulot soit pour les fatiguer
après avoir douché monfils après avoir
bossé même avant de retourner bosser et
bien j'ai pas besoin de m'embêter et je
sors un peu la rapide facile bon pas
forcément cher en très peu de temps et
sari pour ça c'est super cool je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez vous est ce
que c'est une solution qui pourrait vous
intéresser
est ce que vous voyez vraiment l'intérêt
d'avoir une cuisine connecter la cuisine
du futur
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire ces choses dont on a déjà
parlé on va continuer d'en parler tout
ça vraiment hyper intéressant et on voit
qu'on se projette de plus en plus dans
la maison connectée dans un intérieur
connecter pour nous faciliter la vie
vous apportez des solutions simples
concrètes et ce en tout cas c'est
vraiment cool voilà vous remarquez tout
ça vous invite à vous abonner au respect
parce qu'à plein show school qui vont
arriver comme ça c'est franchement bien